dr. Langley for picking University he's
the title of his talk is informational
masking of speech in people with
schizophrenia thank you sure I'm so
happy be here thanks so many people for
inviting me and make this symposium
possible okay that started to mention
some chinese ikea characters so we know
the earliest the chinese character
occurred over 3,000 years ago in tongue
in sheung dynasties so people just
inquired the summer character in animal
bones and two other turtle shells here I
just one month okay over 2,000 new
characters are being recognized so here
I just want want to mention one
character meaning hearing so in Asian
time the people in top in Shang Dynasty
use one year on the left slide instead
of two inside of a wine the present the
two monsters on the right side one added
a superior position and one under the
interposition meaning hearing mainly
deal with multiple wife situation indeed
over the long history for human beings
there are many situation for handling
multiple boy situation sometimes the
situation was so serious so fatal or
even more serious in the modern time so
if we want to recognize one person's
voice this person's voice is masked by
the surrounding sound so generally there
are two types of markings what we call
the energy
at masking and it's just masking
occurred one peripheral neural activity
EDC the pilot signal is over held by
that of the masker leading to the
gridded neural representation of the
signal and the audio purity of the
signal in the laboratory we used a
steady state speech space spectrum noise
as the masking stimulus to generate
energetic masking so for example if we
make a recording from a single auditory
neuron and increase sound gradually you
can see the fine rate increase and
gradually reach the flight freeze so if
we pry the master background making this
neuron fine so the dynamic range of this
neuron will be narrowed causing an
ejection masking now here I just want to
mention the second type of masking even
more important we call information
masking so information masking occurs
when posted signal and the masker are
similar in certain types of the spectral
temporal patterns confuse with one
another particularly when both single
cells are masking sauce a speech due to
the confuse ability of the targeted
masking speech and all the requirement
of the central resource that had that
are devoted the tool does processing of
the masking speech masking speech may
interfere with processes of target
speech and different levels perceptual
level or cognitive level now we want
mill build a link between information
masking and schizophrenia okay here's my
title we know schizophrenia exhibit
impairment are wide assortment of
neuropsychological tasks
recently we just found in from people's
with the school schizophrenia are more
vulnerable to masking especially
informational masking compare their
demographic controls for example we
asked a participant to recognize speech
in a background of either noise or
speech and gradually increases
signal-to-noise ratio you can see for
the first episode of patients they have
a good year okay normal hearing and they
have a small difference in equal in the
threshold compared to their controls but
the wine the master switch from
energetic to informational you can see
bigger difference between patients and
controls in either Forrester episode of
patient and the chronic patients okay 60
years ago a professor named Colin cherry
from I my team okay proposed a very
famous problem is called a cocktail
party problem how do we recognize what
one person is seen where others are
speaking at the same time okay let me
just give a quick explanation of this
problem okay a cocktail party several
people are targeted at the same time and
the one listener want to know what's
going on the other side at the corner of
the room okay this speaker may see
something important for him even though
the voice is weak and the signal of this
speaker combine the ether ear canal into
a compound this listener can also
extract signal from the targeted talker
so this is why why is it happen this is
a cocktail party problem
the beauty of this paper is not only the
proposal of a very famous a problem in
science also suggests some of factors
not making mental facilities to
listeners this factor into summer
acoustic Oh Q's some visual cues and the
spiritual kills so here I just want
mention the effect of the spatial
separation to sound left side and west
side on the right side the left side is
defined as a signal due to the higher
shattering effect the sound from the
right side reach the left year and the
energy become lower causing an increase
in signal to noise ratio and the left a
year so that is the head shattering
effect so provide a better year to the
listener also the song fall from the
left speaker to the left year comes to
the ear early than the right a year so
there is a into auto time difference so
there is a disparity between the two
sound sources in inter all-time defense
so these binaural cues can be used by
the audio to see team is pretty
automatically so this effect can occur
in an ascetical right now if the
cocktail party is held yeah reverb
reverb environment each of these sound
cells produce numerous reflections and
such an environment some people already
provide a solid evidence to show that a
highly river burning environment
significantly reduce the hide a shadow
advantage and of SKUs in 1000 time
defense okay thereby significant
reducing the spiritual separation you
fight however when the masker is a
speech speech of separation still have
some masking effect so thought a kid
suggest
factors other than had a shattering and
the binary processing maybe consider
okay now spatial separation can provide
several abril kills acoustical level
neurobiology level and perhaps psycho
light psychological level so if we can
find some method to remove the first two
levels so we can isolate the third one
so how peephole to handle the
reflections yeah reverberant your
reverberating environment okay let me
take a test we view the war on the right
side okay to produce reflections
actually we do not appeal the war we use
a loudspeaker to simulate the
reflections so we present the record
sound and the reflection sound and a
change the time interval between these
two sauces so one interval is a small
enough listener just receive a single
sounded image as coming from the left
side so this phenomena is called the
president's effect even those on the
level are the same on both side so
listener cannot recognize that instinct
sound the image has come from the right
side so all theoretical explanation of
the presidency effect is based on the
attribute the capture the idea is you
are reverberating environment there are
many songs sauces so you just answered
sauce is producing many many reflections
but auditory system has such ability to
calculate the similarity correlation
between sources because reflections have
a high correlation with each directed
sound waves so they have a high
correlation and the attribute of the
lagging sound are captured by the
leading sound perceptually okay just
make some for several
perceptual field sound the images okay
for example you have a life too loud
speaker and the right lot of speaker and
the present the same sound
simultaneously so wonder song wonder
sound the interval is high we received
the two teams on the imaging so with
reduction of the sound interval the
image it become fused okay and graduate
the impact the ease of the Sun image is
reduced eventually one sounded involve
become zero we just received a single
impact some the image has come from the
frontal area so this is a perceptual
integration now the question is is the
perceptual integration of speech sound
useful ya RAB urban environment we
conduct this study to lot of speakers
present the targeted speech and the
right loud speaker is the leading one so
some image is perceived as come from the
right side because the presidency fact
okay the same Lotus speaker I used to
present the masking speech okay one the
lab when the right a loud speaker is the
leading speaker for the mascot speech
the masking sound image is as coming
from the right side okay so wonder under
this situation one we focus on the
target we have to pay attention to the
masker because they come from the same
spatial location okay when the left now
the speaker is the leading speaker for
the masker the masker image is perceived
as coming from the left side so there is
a perceived special special separation
between the masker and the target okay
it's easy to understand so such a
perceived a speedo separation play a
critical role to improved speech
recognition under the masking is special
and a speech masking now the perceptual
integration with you leading sound and
the like
sound Annie's another audit function we
called primary auditory primary auditory
memory which is the starting point when
people recognize speech yeah Roberta new
environment so memory to keep fine
structure signal of the ringing sound
for shorter period of time allowing the
neural computation of the correlation
meeting leading sound at the liking
sound so wonderfully similarity is a
high enough the attribute of the
lighting sound is captured making the
presentations effect so making the
perceptual segregation when there is a
spatial perceptual segregation between
master and the target the listener can
pay attention to the target and the you
can nor the masker so just improve the
recognition of a target so how about the
schizophrenia okay and there's no
anechoic chamber in psychiatry the
hospital so we need a bring the song to
the hospital we make we use a dummy head
to make a recording of the sound using
in the u.s. moment because when the
sound is recorded by the tummy head and
the playback to the listener listen can
I start feeling the Sun come from speech
is called externalized okay so we bring
the sound at all side psychiatry
hospital and ding hospital we got the
data there okay for the controls you can
see there's a effect of the speed of
separation the circle yeah surprisely
even people with chronic schizophrenia
they have a low score compared to the
controls this tool can use the perceived
espero solution to improve their
recognition of speech okay we go to the
neuro
basis okay contact I from our experiment
okay for the controls perceive the
signal separation can increase neural
activity in several bring regions
outside the auditory system is surprised
okay these spring regions can be divided
two categories one deal with speech
production the others deal with arrow
related response inhibition and the
focus on particular song the sauces yeah
cluster auditory environment and dealing
with audio totally auditory attention to
speech and the high processing load this
is a result from normal people but for
the patients they provided totally
different patterns okay these active the
structures according to the literature
choose reduction in green matter volume
such as decline of functions of these
structures for example the left superb
frontal cortex so according to study by
cursors and colleague the number of
complex sentence in the syntax
production is a correlated with the
activity of the left superb frontal
cortex in control group not not in the
patient group okay also according to
study by covers and colleague in
patients with schizophrenia reduce the
function recruitment in the lab de Co
frontal cortex occurs during listening
to a story with social social in actions
between characters ok now we come back
to the famous paper cherez paper several
other possible cues can be used ok in
addition to spatial kills in my life my
students also found in
there are several queues which is
helpful including the contact pew pews
and the vocal cues so yeah cocktail
party there are many perceptual
cognitive cues available for listeners
for segregating targeted stream from
masking stream so listener to use these
cues diamond dynamically okay also there
is a link between cocktail party problem
and the binding problem I think you
agree with us there are 2 3 MERS problem
in psychology and the neuroscience
according to my understanding they share
the same principles now we know that
schizophrenia people available ok can
use the spatial kills how about the
other kills people with schizophrenia
cannot use ok recently my postdoctoral
just find an interesting phenomena the
time rate pre presenter lip-reading
kills can be used by normal hearing
listeners for a masking speech the ideas
lip-reading you know contains reach
information about the speech accountant
so if we present the breathing in quite
some time later we present the target
speech muscular by sorry present the
target speech multiply irrelevant a
speech so there is a time delay if the
lip reading match the target there's the
improvement of the performance if they
are not matched so the performance is
low natha means the listener can use
both their working memory abilities and
the audio region in the creation
abilities to finish
this task how about the schizophrenia
people indeed schizophrenia together
schizophrenics totally cannot use such
kinda kills okay with God one and we
measure the bold contract we see for the
normal people summer bring activities
that's pretty mega science this brings
include those dealing with biological
motion face visual integration and the
summer bring structure dealing with
attention others dealing with face
working memory because there is a time
delay also some people dealing with
motion planning water arrow response
inhibition but for the people with
chronic schizophrenia once again they
provided different pattern of the neural
activity the same some of the structures
also speed reduction incremental volume
okay now all question is why summer
times functional brain regions in
schizophrenia become hyper when
perceptual cognitive and masking cues
are provided okay particularly both the
bold contrast of the right middle
frontal cortex and that of the
hippocampus pero hippocampus were
enhanced in each of the two patients to
group patient groups when the special
test the other is in the leaping
lip-reading prime test so suggesting
these two brain regions should be paying
more attention so this such as are two
lines of study in the future okay
according to home studies so abnormal
activity in the right middle frontal
contacts in schizophrenia is really to
the deficit in context
facing so we want to find out the summer
bring network that a deal with the thing
analyzed not as just a single feature
okay single test the theme analyze is
one direction also according to a recent
study by Jason the ji-jing g72 which is
very close to schizophrenia these genes
tethers influence verbal working memory
performance in clinical normal
participant with a high risk allow
carriers scoring better than other
groups particularly this behavioral
difference were accompanied by
difference in FM our manager bring
activity in the right parahippocampal
gyrus with the high risk a lil carrier
shooting the significant more be
actively than other groups so I like the
lawyer idea to combine the research and
different levels Jing libels ephemeral
idols bring imaging levels and behavior
levels so this symposium probably can
provide such opportunity for future
studies ok here's conclusion patients
with chronic schizophrenia also with
acoustical verbal he'll lose the
hallucination more more vulnerable to
speech masking than their healthy
controls second patient participant
retains the ability to use the perceive
the speed of separation separation but
not temporal pre present lip-reading to
improve recognition of target speech
against an information I'm asking
inhales controls the am asking ques
increase the board count trust in summer
bring bring structures ready to speech
production selection selective attention
and the irrelevant single inhibition
impatient the participant however that
increase the border contrast in speed a
different pattern from that healthy
controls these stink distinct patterns
for the border contrast in patients we
provide a new pie marker for this
disorder for both the diagnosis and the
investment so the ideas we solve the two
big problem and meantime we may have a
better understanding of the
schizophrenia so some of young people
seem like I'm idea come to my laboratory
you know collaborate with us become my
students you know some people some
students graduate left some a new one
come powder Chow was to one of my PhD
students okay she's a sitting here and
I'm missing them terribly thank you very
much